te donner les noms de la balle
tout le monde est déjà à l'intérieur bye papa
explosion secoue la ville aujourd'hui 20 000
livres pour les noms des Bombers
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on fait les choses
bonjour mr.  Hannassey est de retour c'est
cinq jours de suite maintenant écoutez quelle
fille a été tuée dans l'attentat mr.
Hennessy, s'il vous plaît, découvrez les noms
des bombardiers pour lesquels je travaille pour le gouvernement,
pas des terroristes
pour lesquels j'avais l'habitude de travailler. Je ne sais pas qui sont
les kamikazes. Ne vous croyez pas, c'est
lui.
mardi, vous ne pouvez pas être
là, ils me portent peut-être des forces spéciales de
petite à moyenne taille cette ville
pourquoi ne m'entendez-vous pas veut juste que
vous sachiez qu'il peut vous comprendre ce qui se passe
pense que je sais qui nous a amené sa fille il
nous sommes conscients, mademoiselle, quelqu'un dirait-il une
ville de rire de prière à la recherche principalement de
dopamine,
alors vous avez un membre, vous allez oh mec qui
tourne en rond autour de beaucoup d'entre nous, les
cheveux font à chaque étape du chemin ouvrez-
le au dos de Cooper oh vous n'avez pas
idée à qui tu as affaire
petit cousin privé ils appellent ça une
gifle froide dis une prière mets oui et tu
fais toi